[Musique]
julie salut france par tu sais quelle
heure il est déjà j'ai oublié
complètement là et ben oui ça fait plus
d'une demi heure qu'on t'attend avec
monsieur du snob mais j'avais tellement
de travail que j'ai pas vu le temps
passer enfin c'est pas tant ses parcs en
mai mais si on veut offrir un cadeau à
casimir il faut de plus oui mais écoute
pour gagner du temps
regarde vite ce qu'assure ce ballet
deviennent la friche de même femme on
sait bien que s'il ya quelques siècles
que je suis fort le moment celle à
l'accrocher les mahfoud pikes des arts
c'est pas étonnant qu'il manquait qu il
est où le sceau de choses qui arrivent
on écoute moi je te le répare tout à
l'heure et maintenant yannick mais
justement casimir doit venir balayé les
allées du jardin et cache valley
mais non si ces petites comme il est il
va croire que je lui ai oublié nous
faire la tête pendant deux jours tu as
raison tu as raison alors tu prends un
papier et tu écris casimir casimir le
valais est cassée ne m'allait pas le
genre dès aujourd'hui pas mais ça va
être encore pire il va penser que nous
n'aimons pas sa façon de balayer et que
nous le prions de s'abstenir c'est vrai
ça c'était alors tu écris casimir tu te
fais ce que tu veux mais oui mais si
nous allons chercher un cadeau pour
casimir et qui commencent à bouder
pendant ce temps nous aurons l'air malin
heureusement j'avais pas pensé à ça et
après il serait capable de refuser notre
cadeau écoute
nous allons écrire casimir le ballet
cassez ne t'ont serre par ne t'en fais
pas là à mon avis je vois il va se
demander pourquoi ce mot lui adresser
personnellement oui il va dire
considération personnelle parce que l'on
trouve plus bêtes que les autres
alors on écrit sale morts le ballet est
passé le balai et que défense de
sincères me semble parfait ça ça me
semble parfait alors comme ça
casimir verra que bellaing cassé et puis
pourra pas passer quelque chose contre
lui voilà parti à les aimer chez toi
vite je t'attends tu m' attends ça c'est
la meilleure de la journée
wallons soient pas si de quito et steve
d'accord à 13 heures
[Musique]
tam tam tam
le casque est fermé bonsoir
julie au bonjour vous n'avez pas vu
françois ou julie isoa wii qui sont
partis bon moi je vais balayé le jardin
ils auraient quand même pu maintenant
drain heureusement que je suis de bonne
humeur est pas susceptible les roues
elle balaie le voilà mais qu'est ce que
c'est
le ballet est cassée défense de s'en
servir
ils auraient quand même pu me me
laissait un mahler meilleur état julie
m'avait promis de m'acheter un baleineau
elle n'a peut-être pas voulu que je la
bim
heureusement qu'aujourd'hui je suis de
très bonne humeur
pourtant avec un mot pareils il ya
vraiment de quoi se mettre en colère
le ballet est cassée défense de s'en
servir
il aurait au moins le mettre un mot
gentil comme mon cher casimir le
baleineau est trop beau pour toi celui
ci est un peu cassé comme tu es très
maladroit évite de teint servir je ne
sais pas moi vous voyez un lille ça vous
qu'ils m'ont laissé un vieux balai cas
c'est un
et puis ils ont dit que j'étais trop
maladroits crains c'est écrit en toutes
lettres dans la lettre qu'ils auraient
dû m'écrire un aux tweets
ils sont partis pour que je me
débrouille tout seul et lâche
ah c'est vous vous voilà un pur revenez
pour vous moquer de moi
qu'est ce que tu racontes oui oui et
puis vous m'avez laissé un vieux balai
cas c'est parce que je suis trop
maladroite me servir d'un homme c'est
celui-là le neuf alors pourquoi il car
c'est un massage sont des choses qui
arrivent
et puis vous m'avez laissé tout seul
exprès donc junior vraiment que tu es
trop susceptible
il faut pas se mettre des idées comme ça
dans la tête un ep on est parti acheter
un très joli cadeau un cadeau pour moi
pour toi mais alors vous m'aimez quand
même un peu on t'aime beaucoup beaucoup
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup plus haut
casimir voilà ton cas des réponses
qu'est ce que ça que je crois qu'il te
plaira quand je dis le moi dis moi ce
que c'est teva regarde c'est un appareil
spécial électrique automatique pour
manger des bleus biblia quelle
catastrophe
le marché s'est trompé il nous a donné
un appareil qui était en réparation sur
la boîte
il ya écrit appareil qu'à celui des
fosses de chance et de lille
[Musique]